so have to start this is such an
incredible truth story
talk a little bit about maybe how much
did you know going in what did you learn
from the script
go ahead I didn't know anything about
this story until I read the script and I
I had known actually about the statue of
Balto in Central Park but it was a
complete revelation to me that this
other sort of untold story was was there
and I was excited to work with Willem
and be a part of of telling that for me
I think I met Erickson core before I
even read the script and his take on
nature and his relationship his
relationship to nature because his mom
near and Wilderness First Responder he
really knows what it's like to be out in
the wild and his relationship to animals
really gave me the sense that he had a
real connection to the story and then i
read the story i knew the Balto story
but I didn't know this particular story
of otoko so a lot of us just saw the
movie downstairs and came up to talk to
you it was very I think it's very dusty
in the theaters that are playing this
and I think people should be warned that
and also if you're going to watch it at
home
clean the room first before you watch
the film is that do you think we can
make a message about that of course
right yeah no being seriously it's so
well done and the ending with the music
and the way it's shot like I thought the
cinematography in this was spectacular
beautiful that's Erickson he's director
and he started off as a cinematographer
and he definitely brought brought that
to this and I loved when I just watched
it last night also and did you also find
it a little dusty in the rough super
dusty in my house last night right okay
we were all sneezing right um but I
loved how he separated the different
stories with with color also and when
you see Leonard and the dogs out in the
wilderness there was sort of this
beautiful like
sort of grayish blueish palate and then
it felt a bit warmer when they're in the
house like he took great care with with
how he filmed this and I was also
completely blown away by all the action
stuff because of course Constance is
home keeping keeping down the fort while
he's out there sort of fighting the
elements and I I mean I was literally
like gripping my chest like holding my
face I couldn't believe what they were
able to do it's really breathtaking and
I will say that a lot of this stuff was
done practically yes some places it's
sweetened you know with special effects
and some things were just too dangerous
for the dogs and for me but but really
so much of it was done practically and I
think that really helped the look of it
because a lot of the action sequences we
did we did only only the sequence when
we're going down the ice some of that's
sweetened because you just practically
couldn't do it I was gonna say there's a
certain sequence and that ice thing
where there's no way they're gonna let
you do do that there's just no chance uh
I am curious so one of the things I
thought was so effective is you guys is
really your relationship in the film was
able to be very effective with not a lot
of you know exposition it just felt very
natural talk little talk a little bit
about events from the knife right did
you guys mean one of these things where
you actually did any rehearsal or it's
like you meet each other in the first
day and it's like Boop you're in I don't
know a week before a few days where we
were actually in in our house we got to
settle in the houses yeah and we did we
did some rehearsal because Ericsson was
also very good you know for giving us
room and having us find the scenes
together but I think we just you know
it's a pretty good immediately
I'm curious this is obviously gonna be
streaming on Disney Plus do you get a
free subscription to Disney Plus by
being in a movie I'm gonna look I'm
gonna look into that right
the dusting services reapply it's it's
the kind of thing that you have to ask
for I think they don't expect me to just
give it to you
like everything you guys actually listen
I love animals and I would imagine
working in such proximity to the dogs
and making a movie like this do you sort
of leave set and like I have to get a
dog like or is it's one of the I'm just
curious I've never had a dog because I
came from a really big chaotic family we
had enough animals that's it were but no
I traveled too much but I did I did
through this movie have a completely
different relationship to being with
animals and because we were with them
constantly the same for I've never had a
dog either so for me this was a whole
new experience of getting to spend that
quality of time with them and I traveled
too much but I think a few of those dogs
were were adopted because they were so
lovely and it was and there were a few
people that are were able to take them
home and be friends forever
yeah I would have a tough time yeah come
on before write up before 8:00 all of
them it's one of one of the things but
when you think back in the making of
this thing is there like a day or two
that you will always remember like
something that really stood out from the
filming well every day was pretty
special and it was always it was so it
was quite dramatic because we were so
weather dependent that the schedule was
really erratic we never knew what we
were shooting the next day so you just
look in the sky and that would tell us
what we could do is crazy it's it snowed
about two feet on October 2nd and then
in December there wasn't a flake of snow
so it was really the production-wise
what they've been able to do with with
the practical difficulties that they
faced was really incredible
and it was actually really an intimate
making even though it's a grand scale
that we see like really mostly it was
just William and I so we would be in the
hair and makeup trailer and we would you
know have lunch together and be in that
little house and it was really felt
quite in
and lovely I loved making it I would
know that I'm thinking probably the most
extraordinary days for the days where we
really had to make huge trips into the
mountains because we were sometimes
beyond 8,000 feet so to get there was
you you drive to a certain point then
you take one snowmobile and then you
take another snowmobile and then you'd
have to climb and then it was pretty
incredible it sometimes it took us you
know like hours to get to location and
we don't really have a very short window
to shoot and that before we had to go
back down the mountain before it went
dark it looks spectacular on film um you
guys Congrats on the movie and you're
gonna make a lot of people cry